mientras el presidente macron reitera su
postura frente a Taiwán el presidente
chino ordenó a su ejército sin mencionar
a la isla directamente Que se preparen
para el combate real y vemos esos
movimientos de los cuales acabo de
hablar en poder en estos comentarios al
líder chino
Sí por supuesto le dan una posición
realmente de fortaleza y la oposición en
frente a esta situación de Taiwán china
está decidido a llevar su diplomacia
sobre la isla a niveles antes no no
visto y creo que hoy china encuentra en
las palabras de macron realmente digamos
las líneas diplomáticas que necesitaba
para saber que está en el buen camino en
este sentido
Cómo están afectando esa postura de
macron sobre todo por su reciente visita
china a estas relaciones con otros
socios europeos y sobre todo con Estados
Unidos
bueno ha tenido un impacto realmente
importante y lo que ha mencionado el
presidente francés recordemos que lo que
está buscando el mundo es un poco un
statu quo que después lo menciona
básicamente tratando hacer esa
referencia de que Europa lo que va a
buscar y Francia también es la no
injerencia militar china sobre la isla y
un conflicto en el estrecho con lo cual
me parece que realmente es muy
importante que Francia sea Clara en este
sentido y bueno sus palabras en un
primer momento han generado cierta
disconformidad de Parte de algunos
líderes europeos y en Estados Unidos y
bueno sus declaraciones posteriores han
generado un poco más de Claridad en ese
sentido profesor Carlos el presidente
macrón vive ya una tormenta política de
puertas para adentro por las protestas
en rechazos a su reforma pensional
porque Abre ahora este frente con China
y Taiwán
bueno Francia siempre ha tenido una
política de protagonismo a nivel
internacional creo que macron en ese
vacío que ha dejado Ángela Merkel ha
tratado de Buscar digamos darle más
protagonismo a Francia y la cuestión de
Taiwán es una preocupación mundial más
en una región que estratégica como es el
lindo Pacífico donde la isla fue un rol
fundamental entonces me parece que ahí
lo que ha tratado el presidente francés
Es darle mayor protagonismo a su
diplomacia en estas regiones que son
Realmente de alta tensión y que el mundo
le está prestando mucha atención Más
allá del conflicto de Ucrania con Rusia